- Stupid, stupid shirt.
Look at this hair. Oh my God.
I mean, to be honest, this
is a pretty cool shirt,
except it's a Trump shirt.
(energetic orchestral music)
- My name is Ryan and
I'm a Trump supporter.
- My name is Ali and I
support Hillary Clinton.
- My foremost agreement with Donald Trump
is his economic policies.
- I side with Hillary Clinton because
I'm in line with a lot
of the things that she
has spent her life fighting for,
health care, gun control,
reproductive rights.
- When I find out who people support,
I sometimes judge them immediately.
If I hear of see somebody
supporting Hillary Clinton,
I assume they support a
liar, or someone who's
hiding e-mails, or in scandals.
- I definitely judge Trump supporters.
- People view Trump supporters
as racists, as uneducated,
as liars, and as extremists or radicals.
I'm none of the above.
- It's hard for me to respect
people who support him because
it makes me sick the
things that he says about
people of other races and genders.
(playful orchestral music)
- This is such an old-school hat,
which is probably why people
don't think she's cool.
- Hillary Clinton for
president, boys and girls.
(camera shutter)
(playful orchestral music)
This is making me excited.
- This is why people hate America.
This is why other nations
don't take us seriously.
- And people are gonna love this one.
- I feel like if someone
sees me wearing this,
they have to think it's a joke, right?
(camera shutter)
(playful orchestral music)
- I'm so ready to get out of here,
and get some people's reactions.
- We're gonna find out the
hard way, what this is like.
(playful orchestral music)
So I'm wearing my Hillary hat today.
- Today I'm going to the
Donald Trump golf course,
in Palos Verdes.
Before I went to the Trump golf
course, I called the course
to make sure that it was OK
if I wore Hillary gear there,
and they advised me not to.
- I feel a little bit like a fraud.
- Just a minute ago I was ordering water,
and the man that gave me water said,
"Oh, you're a young man
voting for Hillary,"
and he was like, very surprised about it.
I kind of felt like I was
judged a little bit for that,
for being a young man,
as if I'm not supposed
to vote for Hillary.
- A male co-worker came
up to me and was like,
"Oh, I love Hillary,
I'm voting for her too,"
and it was cool to see a young person,
and a young guy, be really enthusiastic.
- One guy just came up
to me and asked me why
I supported Hillary, I
like being asked why.
- No one has said anything
negative or mean about it,
except actually when I first
walked in, a few people
were sitting around were like, "Really?"
- A couple of Bernie
supporters just yelled at me,
and told me that Hillary is
all for the corporate world,
and that I shouldn't
support the corporate world.
- It's a little weird to wear any sort of
political statement on my body.
It has made me insecure.
- I walked by somebody a
minute ago and they asked me
if I lost a bet, because
of what I'm wearing.
(energetic drums)
- The painful day has come.
- No. Get that off of your
f***ing head (laughs).
- (Ali) You don't like it?
- Ali. Ali!
- Today I'm walking
around my campus at USC,
and I'm already getting
all sorts of dirty looks
from wearing all this Trump gear.
- Get that off! Even if
you're wearing it ironically.
- Somebody just passed
by me and said, "Wow."
A pair of girls just
pointed at me and laughed.
One of my friends told me that he should
follow me around and protect
me because of what I'm wearing.
The most negative reaction I
got for wearing the Trump gear
was the assistant at my
chiropractor's office.
I walked in and she noticed
I was wearing the Trump gear,
and she says to me, "You want
people like me deported?"
And I was pretty shocked, I was like,
"No I don't want you deported,
you're the assistant at
my chiropractor, why would I want that?"
- I didn't realize I would have
such a visceral reaction to it.
It's scarier than I thought it would be.
- Here I am standing at the
Donald Trump golf course resort.
A little old lady just
told me I looked very cute.
Just had a lady come up and ask me to
take a picture with her.
- Now I'm gonna go get
ice cream with Ella.
- You look... Interesting.
- [Ali] Thank you.
- Why are you wearing that?
- We were just going across
the street to get ice cream,
like literally, across the street,
and she wouldn't go with
me in a Trump shirt,
she like, made me take it off.
- I just went to a small Mexican joint.
One of the guys was pointing at me and
looking at me kind of angrily.
He seemed like he didn't like me.
(triumphant orchestral horns)
- It made me realize that
the political climate right now scares me.
There's so much tension.
- I now feel a lot warmer to other
political candidate supporters.
Now I've heard so much of
the rhetoric that comes from
other people, which makes me
understand them a little more.
- When I agreed to do this video,
I had no idea the emotional
tole it would take on me,
to wear Donal Trump stuff.
- When I was wearing the Hillary gear,
getting some positive responses
from people made me realize,
"OK, people feel warm sometimes
with Hillary, I guess."
It's cool to see other
people's points of view.
- I think it's cool to
care about politics because
then it means that you care
about what you believe in,
and you're willing to fight
for what you believe in.
- All people have their reasons for
voting for a certain candidate,
and I can realize that now,
and it shouldn't be something
that we chastise each other on.
Instead, we should be
open to learning about
other people's opinions,
and don't judge people
for what they feel, just listen.